we've learned a lot about derivatives
and now we will use them to to solve
something that is hopefully it may be
kind of useful so let's just start with
a review of the chain rule and I'm going
to write in a different way so let's say
I had the function f of G of X so what
I'm gonna do is I'm gonna actually write
this in a way that might be a bit
foreign to you but I think a little bit
of explanation you'll realize this is
the same thing as the chain rule that we
all know and love that the derivative I
change colors really for no reason just
to change colors sometimes I do that
I'll change colors again the derivative
of F of G at F of G of X is equal to the
rate at which F changes with respect to
G so that's DF 2 DG times the rate at
which G changes with respect to X and
you're saying Sal this looks completely
foreign to me and one you could think
about what I just said and I think it'll
make sense or I could just rewrite this
in the traditional chain rule format
this is really the traditional just what
I just wrote it's a traditional by the
way I've taught you so what when the way
I taught you what's what's the change of
F with respect to G well that's just F
prime of G of x times and what's the
rate of wit at which G changes with
respect to X well that's just G prime of
X right so hopefully this makes sense to
you that these are just two different
ways of writing the chain rule I think
what was this absolutely the Lagrange or
the liveness notation and this is the
other guy but I forget and this actually
makes sense you know just from a
fractions point of view that this term
and that term cancels out and you get
you know that this equals the rate at
which F changes with respect to X so
that out of way let's let's use this to
solve something kind of hopefully a
little bit neat let's say I have
you could say it's up let's say it's one
of those cops that you have at the
watercooler
that's the top of the cup and let's say
the ratio of this cone let's say that
the ratio at any at any point in the
cone the ratio of the radius of the cone
right to the height if this is the
height then the radius is 1/2 I'd okay
at any point right as you know it's a
cone it's a it's a it's a fixed cone
this is Elise our lines on both sides so
that ratio stays fixed right this is one
half so just just to start off with you
know some some you maybe never even
learned this this one's kind of beat
this will help us with the problem later
on what's the volume of exam I'm filling
water up to height H let's say this is
where the water line is all right I'm
writing over everything I've done that's
where the water is in this cone right
what's the volume assuming that that the
height is H assuming that I've let's say
8 centimeters of water what is the
volume of water that I've put in the
cone well if you don't know it and I and
I sometimes well actually later when we
when we do rotations of solids in the
integration modules I can actually prove
this to you but the volume of a cone the
volume of a cone is equal to 1/3 base
times height where the base is actually
kind of you can kind of view it as a
surface area of the water right and
what's what's the base well that's
that's just equal to volume is equal to
1/3 the base is equal to PI R squared
where R is the radius right this is just
kind of a solid geometry review and
what's the radius in this case right
it's 1/3 PI R squared I
R squared times H and in this example
that I said I said that the radius is
1/2 the height so this equals 1/3 pi 1/2
the height right I just replaced it for
R squared times H we haven't done any
calculus yet this is just fancy this is
just complicated not complicated really
just hair it a little bit hairy solid
geometry and if we simplify that we get
volume is equal to let's see so we get
1/2 squared is 1/4 times 1/3 is 112 112
pi and then 8 squared times H H to the
third very interesting now let's start
doing some calculus let's say I think
this might blow your mind let's say I am
pouring water into into this cup into
this cup at a rate of one cubic
centimeter per second and for you metric
jocks you'll know that that is also
that's you know sometimes doctors or
nurses will say one cc and that's also
equal to one milliliter just for other
frames of reference but I like to stay
in centimeters cubed for a second
because we're going to work with
centimeters in multiple dimensions but
let's say we're pouring one centimeter
cubed per second into this cup I want to
know I want to know this is an
interesting question how how fast is the
water level rising right how fast is H
changing the height of the water at the
moment when H is equal to 2 2
centimeters so how do we do that this
just gives us a static picture of if we
know the height we can figure out the
volume but if we figure it out if we
draw if I took the rate of change with
respect to time off of both sides of
this equation something interesting
might happen so let's take the
derivative with respect to time on both
sides so the derivative with respect to
time of the volume well that's just DV d
and what's the derivative with respect
to time of this side of the equation
well it's the rate at which V changes
with respect to H right this this tells
us how fast this is V as a function of H
right so it's going to be it's going to
be DV as a function
how fast is V change with respect to H
times how fast is H change with respect
to T right this is just the chain rule
up here I want to think about this a
little bit it might not seem obvious but
all we're doing is the chain rule it's a
little confusing because I had no T's in
this equation before and all of a sudden
I'm taking a derivative with respect to
T but let's just say that H actually is
a function of T which which we actually
know it is it is so let's then just
solve that so DV the derivative of V
with respect to T is equal to the
derivative with respect to a V with
respect to H well that's easy
the derivative of a V with respect to H
is just this is just a simple so 3 times
1 12 right that's 3 12 that's 1/4 pi so
we could just write PI over 4 H squared
right so that's this part and then let
me change colors and then this part is
just still so I can rewrite in this new
color th DT times D H DT so you're
saying Sal what have you down done I
said the chain the rate at which the
volume is changing with respect to time
is equal to PI over 4 times the height
squared times the rate at which the
height is just changing with respect to
time so can this solve the problem for
us let me let me see if I have some
space up here let me try it well I'm
just confuse you if I go up there well
what do we know we know the rate at
which the volume is changing with
respect to time right one centimeter
cube per second squared so we could say
DV over DT is equal to 1 I'm going to
get rid of the unit's most physics
instructors would cringe
but one centimeter cubed per second is
equal to PI over 4 right this is just
this one is just DV the rate at which
volume is changing with respect to time
PI over 4 8 squared we know what H is
right now H is 2 so it's 2 squared times
the 4 right that's just we said that H
the height is 2 right then so 2 squared
is 4 times D H DT so this cancels out
and we get 1 is equal to PI times d h dt
and we solve for d h dt we get let me
make sure not to confuse you that the
rate in which the height of water is
changing with respect to time is just 1
over pi fascinating
so or 1 over PI centimeters per second
so we could figure out what this number
is is going to be like point I think
what point 3 something so point 3
something centimeters per second is the
rate which is the height of the water
level is going to change as I put one
centimeter cubed a volume into this cup
for a second I have probably confused
you you may want to watch this again and
I'll do a couple more videos with these
rates of change problems because these
tend to confuse people but once you get
the hang of it I think you'll see that
they're they're not so bad I'll see you
the next presentation